apple's new macbook pros come in two
sizes the 14 inch that i have right here
and the 16 inch and this year everything
is totally different because both of
them can be configured with the same m1
pro and m1 max chips so in this video
i'm going to answer if there are any
downsides with going with a 14 inch and
are there any upsides or benefits with
going with the 16 inch because both of
these models have the 10 core on bend
cpu and the 16 core unbind gpu so we're
going to be testing a lot of stuff like
the design portability the speakers the
performance the cooling systems thermal
throttling and much more now before we
begin i know that one of the biggest
questions that you guys have is the
battery life differences so as you can
see both of them are charged to 100
so let me go ahead and unplug the
charging cables and let's get right into
it starting with the design in terms of
the footprint obviously from that top
camera you can tell that the 14 inch is
much smaller so it's gonna be more
portable easier to carry around so if
you're always on the go taking your
macbook you should probably consider
that and we'll see if there's any
downsides so just flipping it on top
there you go you can see
that huge huge difference and if you're
wondering about the weight the 14 inch
is actually 3.5 pounds and we're going
up to 4.7 and just feeling in my hand
i could definitely feel the extra weight
in the extra heft and man you do not
want to be holding this like this for
too long because in reality this 14 inch
is much much lighter now with that said
there are some benefits to the larger
size and weight you're getting a 100
watt hour battery on the 16 inch
compared to 70 on the 14 inch and we are
going to be testing that at the end of
this video we're going to see how much
both of them are left with after all the
benchmarks and everything and because
the 16 inch is actually a bit thicker
than the 14 inch i think you are gonna
be getting a better cooling system and
we're definitely going to be testing it
out you know what let's actually go
ahead and take off the bottom covers to
see if there are any fan size or cooling
system differences so i took out all the
screws and before i take these covers
off i do want to mention something very
important if you match the specs up on
both of these macbook pros there is a
200 difference going from the 14 inch to
the 16 inch so it seems like you're just
getting the larger size but let's go
ahead and see if you're getting anything
else let's take these off
oh my goodness look at that fan size
difference
it is literally like twice as large
in terms of the footprint but these fans
are thicker
they're taller look at that and then as
you can see right here we have the m1
pro chip but i'm seeing a huge
difference look at the thickness of that
heat pipe going through to the fans
right there and look it is much thicker
on the 16 inch model not only that but
over here the fins are longer compared
to the ones on the 14-inch so just
looking at this there should be a big
difference in terms of the cooling
system performance and wait a minute
here is another difference that i'm sure
none of you guys were expecting because
on the 14 inch we have an ssd layout of
four slots or four basically pogo
sections for them and only two of them
are filled so we got two ssd chips these
ones are empty however on the 16 inch
there is a total of eight
and the weird thing is that there are
four filled in here and one filled in
there which doesn't really make sense
because on the base 512 gig model
usually ssd comes in variations of 128
gigs so each one of these four is
probably 128 gigs but why are we getting
the extra fifth chip that doesn't really
make sense unless apple threw it in for
like redundancy or something without
telling anybody i don't know but we are
going to be testing out those ssd speeds
and finally there is a big difference in
terms of the speakers even though apple
said that the 14 inch gets the same six
speaker system as the 16 inch check this
out the subwoofers on the 16 inch are
massive they're like almost i don't know
twice as big or 66 percent larger on the
16 inch compared to the 14 and they're
also thicker taller as well and as far
as the speaker port itself the one on
the 14 inch is flat and the 16 inch is
definitely different but the biggest
difference is that the tweeter section
for the 14 inch is actually on the side
of the logic board and it's quite small
whereas on the 16 inch it actually goes
under the logic board and if you watch
ifix's tear down the tweeter is actually
pretty huge compared to how small this
one looks so because of that physical
size difference i'm extremely excited to
test out the speaker quality in just a
minute but first i want to give a shout
out to our giveaway yes we are giving
away a 2500
m1 pro macbook pro and the only thing
you have to do is click subscribe make
sure you're subscribed and leave a
comment down below because what we're
going to do is we're going to take one
of the launch week videos that we're
making we're going to choose one at
random and then choose a random comment
from that video and we are gonna ship
that macbook pro to the winner
regardless of where they are in the
world and regardless of what kind of
taxes import taxes whatever we will ship
it to you so definitely subscribe right
now now opening up the lids there is a
difference in displays so let's get
right into that first of all there's a
display resolution difference on the 14
inch you have basically a 3k display and
on the 16 inch you have a 3.5 k so it
has 30 percent more pixels so you're
basically getting better resolution but
of course that's just to compensate for
the larger 16 inch display the actual
sharpness or the pixels per inch is the
same at
254 now that definitely does make the
16-inch more immersive if you're gonna
be doing things like playing games
watching videos watching movies and
that's actually the reason that i
personally bought the 16 inch but that's
just me now with that said both of them
have the same notch right at the top of
the display with the same webcam quality
and everything else however because the
16 inch has a larger display as you can
see in that top camera the notch is
actually less noticeable because it
takes a smaller portion of the display
compared to the 14 inch now as far as
everything else they're both identical
displays they both get mini led
technology up to 1600 nits peak
brightness when you're watching hdr
content so that's very nice and they
both also get these same pro motion 120
hertz displays so as far as the quality
there's no difference there now going a
little bit lower down to the keyboards
they are basically identical and as far
as the track pads the one on the 16 inch
is quite a bit larger but in terms of
how it performs it's also identical so
no big differences there and with that
said let's go ahead and get into the
speaker quality comparison and before i
begin i do want to mention a little bit
of a difference here you can see the
speaker grills on the 16 inch are much
wider right there and that's because the
tweeter itself is wider compared to the
one on the 14 inch so let's go ahead and
begin
[Music]
all right wow guys even though apple
said that the 14-inch gets the same
speaker system i can definitely hear the
difference the biggest one is actually
in the base the 16 inch has louder and
deeper bass and maybe because of that it
seems like the highs are more pronounced
on the 14 inch maybe because the base
isn't kind of like overpowering it or
anything but i did hear a little bit of
sharper highs on the 16 inch with those
larger tweeters so let us know your
thoughts on the speakers down in the
comment section below now with the
speakers out of the way i want to start
getting into our performance
benchmarking starting off with that
storage speed test now i do want to
mention that this specific model
actually has a one terabyte ssd so the
price is actually identical between
these two twenty five hundred dollars
here and twenty five hundred dollars for
the base 16 inch so if you wanted to
spend the extra 200 on ssd instead of
going for the larger size you can do
that but right over here to the side we
have a 14 inch with the base 512 ssd so
let's go ahead and test out the ssd
speeds with black magic disk test we
have our speeds and this is actually
very interesting just going from the 14
inch to the 16 inch with the same 512
gigabyte ssd you're getting 230
megabytes per second faster for both the
right and the read even though it's the
same ssd size however on the 14 inch
going up to the one terabyte you're
getting a huge boost in write speed a
thousand megabytes per second right
and 300 read over the 16-inch 512 so it
definitely scales with the larger ssd
now before we get into the real world
tests that are actually going to put
some stress on these systems i want to
run geekbench 5 really quick just to
prove to you guys that they're both the
m1 pro unbind and there you go we have
our scores and as you can see the
performance is basically identical so i
just tested the geekbench 5 metal
graphics test and i was not expecting
this difference
the 16 inch is actually scoring around
1500 points higher than the 14 inch and
this is actually the highest score that
we got on the 14 inch m1 pro model that
is very interesting now that might
actually be because of the differences
in the cooling system so because of that
we're going to be running a gaming
stress test this is 3d marks wildlife
extreme i'm going to turn on the
unlimited mode and then after that i'm
going to do a couple of loops to see if
we can stress the gpu and get some
differences whoa what the heck the 14
inch is actually faster i was not
expecting that based on the metal score
and that may be because metal tests a
bunch of different tests and this is
just gaming by itself so i guess there's
no difference for gaming so with that
said what i'm going to be doing is
running that loop the test only just
began not too long ago the 14 inch is
already at 93 degrees celsius 2400 rpms
on the fans look at that the 16 inch
says the fans are off they haven't even
turned on yet it's only at 81 degrees
celsius guys this is absolutely insane i
cannot believe it the fans on the 16
inch are still off 86 degrees celsius 96
degrees 4 000 rpms on the 14-inch while
the 16-inch it's still off and now i'm
audibly hearing those fans 4 500 rpms
yep they're getting loud 4700 they're
still off on the 16-inch finally it hit
90 degrees celsius and the fans are
turning on 1 600 rpms compared to 4 800.
we're four minutes into the test and i
still can't hear the fans on the 16 inch
they're still only at 1 500 rpms and it
was able to cool down to 86 degrees
celsius well the fans on this one are
loud so basically what this is showing
is already only four minutes into a 100
gpu workload that basically shows off
gaming performance so if you're going to
be doing a lot of gaming the 16 inch is
looking very very promising with the m1
pro chip because i still can't hear it
we're now about six minutes into the
test and the 16 inch is killing it still
at 1500 rpms which as you can see right
here is basically idle it's keeping the
temps in check which is so impressive
but i am worried for the 14 inch because
this is just the m1 pro 16 core gpu
imagine the 32 core m1 max in this
chassis how is it going to perform well
we've got that covered because we're
going to be comparing the m1 max on the
14 inch compared to the m1 max on the 16
inch to see the thermal throttling and
fan noise differences so definitely
subscribe so you don't miss out on that
video we're now 10 minutes into the test
and the 16 inch is still sticking to
around 1 500 rpms which is actually the
minimum amount for the fans to be on
otherwise they would be off so it's
still staying below 90 degrees celsius
89 right now and on the 14 inch we're
sitting at 94 degrees celsius and around
4 600 rpms which is about two-thirds of
the way to full speed now i do want to
mention that the 13-inch intel macbook
pro the previous one would be going
crazy blaring full speed fans very loud
at this point and in reality even though
i can't hear the fans they are nowhere
near as loud as basically any gaming
laptop out there but between these two
if you are doing gaming you definitely
want the 16-inch so the point that i'm
trying to make is that if you're doing
any kind of tasks that is graphics
intensive like for example blender that
i have open right here you're going to
be seeing the same exact performance as
you can see with these results 9.44
compared to 9.29
however the 14 inch is gonna be louder
in terms of the fan noise and it's gonna
run hotter that's the only difference
you're gonna notice between these two in
anything graphics related so with the
graphics now out of the way let's move
over to the cpu side and see the
temperature and noise differences with
the processing tasks like cinebench r23
which is a 3d rendering app that fully
utilizes the cpu cores let's run this
stress test it's only been around 30
seconds and the fans on the 14 inch are
already on at 2400 rpm 95 degrees
celsius 16 inch once again the fans are
still disabled only at 81 degrees that's
actually very interesting i'm about to
pull out our thermal camera here in just
a minute 100 degrees celsius 101 degrees
celsius on the 14 inch it looks like
this is actually gonna thermal throttle
102 degrees what i don't think i've
never seen 100 degree over 100 not a max
i have it how is that possible 103 now
what in the world 104 on gpu cpu
performance core 8. wow 105. is apple
really letting it get that hot
i guess they are man that is extremely
hot 106. now we're finally getting 92
degrees celsius oh the fan just turned
on 1700 rpms it's still at that minimal
level compared to 3700
on the 14 inch it's been just about nine
minutes into the test and i've pulled
out our seek thermal camera and as you
guys can see right here we have a hot
spot on the display 43 44 degrees
celsius and as you can see we have a
huge hotspot over the center of that
keyboard now moving over to
the 16 inch the hottest spot is actually
41 degrees right there on the display
that's where the exhaust is coming out
of but take a look at that in the center
of the keyboard that red hot spot is
much smaller on the 16 inch and you can
see that white bar that's actually the
larger heat pipe that i guess is getting
rid of a lot more heat and looking at
the temps on the 16 inch it's at 91
degrees celsius 2 000 rpm which that's
like i don't know like 15 20
compared to 66 percent two-thirds of the
way on the 14-inch 4500 rpm with 102
degrees celsius this thing is running
super hot now what this shows is is that
if you're doing a task that maxes out
the cpu and then puts a load on the gpu
the 16 inch has enough thermal headroom
to not throttle whereas the 14 inch is
already right there at the limit where
you are having a much higher chance of
throttling wait a minute the test just
finished what the heck i was not
expecting this
we're basically getting the same score
only what 28 points higher on the 16
inch i wasn't expecting that because it
seemed like the 14 inch was throttling
like crazy but it looks like apple is
actually allowing it to get insanely hot
106 degrees celsius so they're giving
you the full performance not caring
about the temperatures and not really
caring about the fan speed so that's
actually a pretty good sign in terms of
performance
now if you are worried about the temp
getting that hot 106 degrees we're gonna
leave a link down in the description
below to tg pro which actually allows
you to monitor the fan speeds and the
temps and create a custom fan profile
like you can see right here you're able
to make the fans max out after reaching
90 degrees celsius so it's going to keep
the temps down so you're not going to
have those thermal throttling issues
potentially or you're not going to get
that hot and risk having any long-term
degradation which maybe you don't but
that will give you some peace of mind
now moving on to our next test we have
logic pro for music production this is
the new logic benchmark this is
extremely unrealistic because we're
pushing them to the max trying to see
how many instruments we can run at one
time without overloading so keep in mind
nobody's really gonna have that many
tracks at once as you can hear they're
both playing back and the cpu load is
going up to what 68
and now about 20 seconds in i'm seeing
about 10 degrees difference on the
temperatures 77 right there 88 90
degrees celsius on the 14 inch so it's
starting to get hot however
the fans actually haven't turned on so
this has been running for a couple of
minutes and on the 16 inch we're sitting
at that same idle 1500 rpms 89 degrees
celsius but on the 14 100 degrees
celsius and the fans are at around 3 300
rpm so basically you're going to be
getting the same level of performance
but the fans are going to be running
louder and the system is going to be
hotter on the 14 inch just like we saw
before now if you're interested in the
bend model the base 2 000 14 inch
macbook pro with the a core cpu that one
might actually run cooler than this one
so we are going to be testing out the
bend versus unbend that we have right
here to see if there are any thermal
differences or performance differences
with the 8 to 10 cores so definitely
subscribe now moving on let's get into
photo editing for all you photo editors
out there now in terms of the real world
editing the photo doing brushes making
changes you're going to have the same
performance because it's not really
going to stress the cpu that much but in
terms of exporting it does actually hit
a hundred percent cpu load so let's go
ahead and do that and see if there's any
performance differences the test is
finished and they're both basically the
same one minute and 23 seconds now in
terms of the photo editing experience
max is actually saying that he does a
lot of photo editing and he says he
would prefer the smaller portable size
because with photo editing you're not
really losing out on that much screen
real estate because you have all your
controls and it's not very limiting and
it's nice to have the extra portability
but for video editing this is where the
larger 16 inch comes in handy because
there is a lot of stuff going on as you
can see we have stacked files on the
timeline and having that extra screen
real estate is really really nice
because we're not only seeing more stuff
on the screen but we're having a larger
frame for the image that we're editing
so if you mostly do video editing then i
would honestly recommend going for that
larger 16 inch macbook pro but let's go
ahead and export and see if there's any
advantages with the larger model so what
i have right here is a regular 4k
h.264 file project this is actually the
most common format and this is the exact
format that we shoot all of our videos
in so let's do this export test and show
you guys the differences bam there you
go they both finished at two minutes in
55 seconds and there was barely any cpu
or gpu load that's because the encoders
the video encoders are taking care of
this export so for most people doing
common video editing there's literally
going to be no difference between these
two but with that said let's get into
some extreme tough video editing so this
right here is 8k
canon raw from the r5 with two luts on
top this actually is not supported by
the media engines the encoders or the
decoders so this is going to be very
tough let's export all right so in this
test the gpu is 100 maxed out on both
with around 60 to 70 cpu usage the 16
inch is still sticking to around 1800
rpm
while the 14 inch is maxing it look at
that 5300 rpm
and oh the 16 inch just finished
and yep the 14 inch is literally right
behind it basically the same score but
right at the end there 6000 rpm on the
fans
and it's getting pretty loud all right
we're two minutes in and the fans on the
14 inch are fully maxed out and the cpu
is at 100 degrees celsius it is getting
loud and now five minutes into the test
the 16 inch is about halfway on the fans
and the cpu is staying nice and cool and
here we are seven minutes into the test
and surprisingly with those crazy
differences in the cooling system
they're both at around 68
finished i was not expecting that i
honestly thought that the 14 inch would
be thermally throttling oh man it's
finally starting to slow down and that's
actually because it's down clocking
because of the battery life three
percent battery life on the 14 inch it's
about to die and at the same time 36
on the 16 inch so there you go that's
the battery life difference that's very
impressive we've got to plug this in max
can i see that so now it finally got
quiet but that's because it was down
clocking the gpu the fans finally spun
down and it's kind of funny because i
still don't hear
the 16-inch even at 3000 rpm 86 degrees
celsius that is so impressive and there
you go the 16 inch finished at 10
minutes and 48 seconds but obviously our
tests got messed up because of the
battery life on the 14-inch but in
reality if we had enough battery life
they would have both finished at the
same time so the crazy thing is even
with the throttling going on there was
no performance difference they were both
neck and neck the only real difference
was the extreme temperatures on the 14
inch and the annoying fan noise but once
again i want to remind you guys about
that battery life difference under the
same load we both unplugged them at the
same time the 16 inch at that point was
left with 36 battery life and 3
on the 14 inch so that is a nice extra
level of headroom in terms of battery
now with that said we've been shooting
this video for around three to four
hours so that's exactly what you should
expect from the 14 inch when you're
putting it under a lot of pressure
however with the 16 inch you should be
expecting about five to six hours which
is very impressive because the old intel
i9 16 inch only lasted about three hours
before the battery was dead so with all
of that tested and compared what did we
learn and what conclusion can we draw
well for the extra two hundred dollars
you're getting the larger display you're
getting better speakers you're getting a
faster ssd at the same base 512 gigs but
the biggest deal is that throughout
everything that we tried to throw at the
16 inch it was staying silent in
basically every single test which is
super impressive while the 14 inches
fans were almost always on in every test
that we were running and on top of all
of that you get the extra battery life
with the 16 inch so in my personal
opinion if there's any way you can spend
the extra 200
on the 16-inch do it because you're
getting a ton of advantages and the only
reason you should ever be buying the
14-inch is if you absolutely
need the extra portability and with that
said i guess it's nice to know that
you're not sacrificing any performance
by going with the smaller size you just
have to deal with the extra fan noise
and the worst battery life so there you
guys go hopefully you learned something
new from this video that can help you
make a decision between these two sizes
and if you enjoyed it definitely click
the circle above to subscribe and
comment down below to enter our giveaway
and by the time you're watching this our
other videos like the bend versus unbend
as well as the 16 gig versus 32 gig ram
stress test may already be up so
definitely check them out right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]